[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I like to think of it dear Travis
and Oh Travis what are you doing here
for this very weird and short and
special episode of dear Hank and John
well I'm glad you asked basically what's
happening is the McElroy brothers have
decided that we are going to like a
virus spread throughout everyone else's
podcasts and take them over that would
be a lot easier than just starting more
of our own so actually by next week
you'll be replaced with Griffin and then
Justin will join us then week after and
then it'll just be more my brother my
brother I feel like like dear Hank and
John grew at a fairly fairly steady rate
until we started telling everybody that
my brother and my brother my brother my
brother and me existed and then everyone
was like oh why am i listening to this
dumb advice podcast from two brothers
when I can be listening to this amazing
much funnier podcast from three brothers
so I don't know anyone I think that
happened to everyone like I think like
cereal solid drop off when people
realized my brother my brother and me
existed This American Life yeah a lot of
people I've seen that droughts don't
feel bad it's like the opposite it's
like the macro I bump but not a bump
alright the macro some reclamation I
call the rump mm-hmm exactly
you are in fact here because we're doing
a thing you and me and the guys from
welcome to night Vale and also yeah
brother John and and there's very little
time left to support the IndieGoGo
campaign and so we are doing a special
mini episode of dear Hank and John with
Travis McElroy you know John and we
which we will answer a few questions but
first we will talk about pod con tell me
about pod con Travis what why why did
you say yes when I when I pitched this
idea to you well first and foremost one
of the reasons I was very excited about
it is even though I think too many
people podcasts seem like they've been
around forever
mm-hm it's still such a new media and
we're still figuring it out but the the
the whole sphere has really blossomed in
the last couple years and I'm not gonna
say we're the first people to ever do it
Podcast convention but any opportunity
to bring everybody together and really
kind of cement it as an art form he's so
interesting to me especially with a
focus on production and like the shows
themselves and not just the listening
but the creating of them he's so
important and building the community of
podcasters and podcast consumers he's so
important I love bringing those people
together so we can talk about the
creation what people like what we think
you know is developing in in the art in
the space all of that stuff and so when
you said hey I want to bring people
together under the banner of podcasts I
was on board from like the word go I was
so excited and like the thing to
remember also is that everybody who
makes podcasts is also a huge fan of
podcasts so we also just want to get
together and celebrate and watch our
friends to do their thing that they do
so well so like when you came to me and
like hey I've been talking to the guys
of welcome to night Vale like I was
starstruck I'm a huge fan of welcome to
Ikea I'm a huge fan of yours and of
John's and like the people that we have
coming to the show like I'm just as
excited to go and interact with the
people who consume my show as I am to go
and meet the people who create the shows
that I love so it's there's such a
wonderful blending and getting to go as
both a creator and a fan it's so
exciting I'm so happy about it I'm
really looking forward to it I hope
people are too because there's gonna be
some really amazing guests and you know
even more every day it feels like we get
somebody else on board and it's going to
be this really awesome event that I
really hope people come to well I know
that people will come to it because what
people have already gotten their tickets
on the indiegogo tickets will be
available after the crowdfunding
campaign ends we're doing the
crowdfunding campaign so that we can
sort of have a better idea of how many
people we can offer support to when
we're inviting them to the conference so
like there's one thing to say like hey
we want to want you to be on stage we
want you to do this fun thing but it's
another thing to say and also we can pay
for your flight out and your hotel room
so you have to worry about that the
price will go up after the end of the
campaign which is on Monday
the next Monday after this is uploaded
to like two or three days from right now
when you're listening to it prop to this
probably and some of the ticket levels
won't be available at all so some of our
higher end levels will not be available
so check it out save some money and come
on out to popgun and and we should also
say in that IndieGoGo campaign it's it's
not just your rewards don't stop at
admittance there's like meet and greets
that you can pay for you know become a
sponsor at that level or like a thumb
drive full of episodes or swag bags or a
lot of different levels and a lot of
cool stuff that you can get and also
support an awesome endeavor that you can
then participate in you win twice if you
support pod con and the other thing is
that during the campaign and also
afterward we we have a perk that's for
remote attendants if you can't come to
Seattle for a lower price you can get
all of the stuff that we are doing at
the event delivered to your favorite
podcast feed app so that you can listen
to it because that's what you do anyway
and I promise I'm pretty sure there's
got real pretty fun stuff to listen to
anyway it's gonna be good and we we're
gonna have a good time but I also wanted
to answer some questions from our
listeners if you if you're down for that
have you listened to your Hank John yeah
cuz it's a lot like my brother my
brother Ruby well sometimes I'm
listening to one and I can't tell if I'm
listening together but that's okay so
they're both great do you want to Yahoo
what wait where am i this could very
well be a yahoo what would happen if the
flood went to Jupiter it's from a
preschool teacher in Seattle I took this
question because I assumed that this
preschool teacher is gonna come to pod
con because this preschool teacher is in
Seattle so come on out the kids that I
teach we're asking about droughts and
floods and why they happen things were
going well until one child asked me in
her most serious voice what would happen
if the flood went to Jupiter and I had
no good answer for her she wants to know
what a cataclysmic flood would do to the
solar system I don't have a good answer
and I've asked NASA and Neil deGrasse
Tyson and Randall Munroe and have gotten
no answer so now it is down to Hank
Travis this is amazing and I'll tell you
why when you first posed the what would
happen if the flood I saw like capital T
capital F the flood and my first thought
was this is like the Democrats album
yeah it's either a band or it's like
some kind of weird disease or like an
all-consuming demon I think that if the
flood were a band and they went to
Jupiter it would be an opportunity for
great scientific progress I don't know
why we would have sent them and not
astronauts also probably they would die
well yeah awful hard to get to Jupiter
so I'd you know let's not send anyone
here's the problem with this I I've
taught kids I've worked with kids on
different various projects and I've
directed like plays with kids in it and
there's a certain age of child that like
they you can't just look them in the eye
and say that's not a thing like that's
it don't it won't
that's not it like but also there is no
actual answer to the question that's
asked right like right suddenly and
really put you on the spot of like huh
okay I can't just tell you that that's
nothing and not to worry about it but
but it's nothing don't worry about well
I mean so I'm at so so what my mind went
to like what like like what is Jupiter's
version of a flood so like a lot of
water goes to Jupiter and in my head a
lot of water going to Jupiter is like a
massive like dark interst
interplanetary or interstellar comet
storm that somehow got thrown off the
Oort cloud of a passing solar system
billions of years ago
and then suddenly like this giant like
wave of like Kuiper belt like objects
these big ice balls suddenly slams into
Jupiter and if that happens like it's
not gonna be precise enough that it's
just gonna slam into Jupiter like it's
gonna be a solar system wide comet flood
and we're all gonna die do you ever have
questions that like you know you could
probably look up but you don't want the
answer to because then it would ruin
like your hypothetical thought
experiment
I've had that thought where I thought
what if we built like a shuttle a rocket
spaceship what have you mm-hmm and put
on and we're able to put on it like sure
I ten thousand gallons of water and we
just like flew that to Mars and just
like dropped it off Travis what what's
your what's what's the goal of your of
your water plan here I might I might
have a number I might have a number of
bad news is for you
well here's the thing like I know I
realized that like Mars doesn't have an
atmosphere the same as Earth yeah but
like what impact would it have to
suddenly introduce like a huge possibly
impossible why as long as we're doing a
hypotheticals like a million gallons of
water onto a planet that doesn't have a
you know active it doesn't have water on
it well like how would that impact the
planet what it'd just float away and be
nothing oh well I
so the situation with Mars is that
there's already a lot of water there
it's like it's like what as much water
as there is on earth it's just all
frozen and wait what yes Hank what go on
so a lot of water on Mars it has it has
water ice everywhere we look it's just
below the surface there's ice caps yeah
everywhere we look there's lots of water
on Mars what happens to to the water on
the very surface is that it Sublime's
away which is when what happens when a
solid turns directly into a gas and then
it it ends up in the atmosphere of Mars
which is very thin the atmosphere does
not have enough pressure to have liquid
water on the surface so if you had
liquid water on the surface it would
immediately turn into a gas would just
boil even at the very low temperatures
on Mars and then very over like
geological time the solar wind blows
away Mars's atmosphere like like the
high-energy particles from the Sun hit
Mars's atmosphere and knocks those
molecules into space and they don't come
back and so that's where a lot of Mars's
water has gone and so only the stuff
that's under this surface or the stuff
that like never gets hit by a lot of
sunlight which is what causes it to
sublime I think for the most part in the
place sticks around so so all this so
when we look at it from far away all we
see is this dirt but when we poke it
just a little bit you find a little bit
ice everywhere everywhere we've looked
so let me see if I get this straight
you're trying to tell me that all
planets have water on them God do not
say that
what do not say that but I'm pretty sure
okay what if I haven't said Mars what if
I said any other planet well if they
like the thing is like there are it's
not the presence of water that is like a
super great thing it's the presence of
liquid water and no body in our solar
system has conditions on the surface
that would allow for surface liquid
water there are however several places
that probably have subsurface liquid
water and that for all we know have
giant whales hanging out eating each
other under the surface like making
baskets and and singing songs in their
much more advanced languages than in
ours
so we just got to go knock and see all
right well I think that answers the
question of what would happen if the
flood went to Jupiter I think that I
want to have a science podcast with you
now
well here's the thing Hank what I've got
is a very curious but lazy mind so I
think of these things but then I have no
urge to do any independent research I'd
rather just think through it myself I
used to have that feeling about a
philosophy I didn't want to taint myself
with the ideas of others yes because
that's you know what when you're a 16
year old that's like the most
pretentious thing that you can possibly
think and so of course that's what I
thought was like I don't want to read
other people's ideas I want to have my
own perfect ideas all on my I don't want
to think like like I don't yeah I want
to come up with the best idea all by
myself
I give that a lot with like engineering
and inventions like I I spent I remember
very clearly I spent a day like
contemplating fountains and how ancient
Romans would have made fountains work
without electricity and like without you
know being able to have like pumps and
stuff and so like rather than look it up
I just like spend the day thinking
through how I would do it and I was
pretty close
then after a day like went and like did
the research I was like yeah that's
about what I came up with and like it's
just kind of like am I like a kind of a
self mind Trussell to be like could I've
been an inventor in Rome yeah totally
what you're basically Archimedes Yeah
right
it was easy to invent stuff back then
cuz nothing existed Travis do you want
to ask the last question here I do my
family and I are on vacation for a week
in Martha's Vineyard up until this point
everything has gone well
however our situation just took a turn
for the worse
I have discovered something horrifying
about the other members of my family
they all eat their popsicles by biting
them with their teeth
this is incredibly disturbing to me as
someone who like a normal person does
not bite their popsicles yeah Travis put
emphasis on all of the caps there were
lots of all that's what it's there for
yes so first of all like uh have you
just never eaten popsicles around your
family before like is this like like
only at Martha's Vineyard have you ever
encountered a popsicle or it's possible
it was it might have been like a usual
suspects moment where like they saw
their family bite the popsicles and
suddenly every occurrence of seeing
their family eat popsicles like flash
through their brain and they're like oh
my god it's been this way the whole time
my god though no I guess okay okay I was
thinking possibly it was also like other
like like other family members like
they're they're hanging out with like
their cousins and so all like the
brothers and sisters and parents eat
popsicles like normal people but then
all the extended family are just
chomping down with their titanium teeth
how do you eat wait how do you eat
popsicles I die I don't really eat
popsicles but what I do a likely story
I do I'm a I'm a sucker like lick and
suck lick and suck I might at like close
to the end like get my teeth involved a
little bit just cuz like things are
getting precarious you know and like at
the at the end of the pot like this is
like it's only on one side of the stick
and it's starting to slide down and you
just gotta like take care of it you know
I'm
not to be a rebel but if we're talking
about those like frizzy pops you know
the ones in like the plastic tubes
I'll just patiently wait for them to
just kind of slush up and then just
drink them give me a like otter pops
yeah yeah yeah or just or just don't put
them in the freezer at all and just like
cut it open and have a drink I like it
to be chilled um I like a refreshing icy
beverage I'll just put it in put it in
your tea just like like microwave 1c
okay you don't know if you don't like it
too the question asker I will say that
the as a person with sensitive teeth the
idea of is like biting into frozen past
like ice cold
yes that's horrifying to me but I can
also understand like it's a weird test
of patience - it's a popsicle without
biting it yeah well this is this is like
this my problem goes beyond sensitive
teeth problems into this which is like
like like it's hot out your own vague
here on summer vacation you you're not
having a popsicle so you like get the
maximum amount of sugar in your body at
the maximum speed you are cooling your
body and having a refreshing treat like
what kind of glutton do you have to be
to be like I remember and popsicles all
gone Hank I'm sorry to disagree but
you're not sitting on your porch after a
hard day's work enjoying an ice-cold
lemonade you've grabbed a popsicle for
speedy cooling down so you can move back
out into the world what if her family or
their family I don't know who this
person is what if their family is like
comprised mostly of nine-year-olds well
they're just really busy they think well
no but they just don't have the patience
to like and now the popsicle for an hour
and a half what kind of popsicles are
you eating yeah they're really gonna
savor it in your in your dream well
that's that this is an interesting thing
about like having a popsicle in Montana
in the winter which is I don't know why
you would do that but if you're outside
having a popsicle it'd be much harder to
eat the popsicle because it would stick
like your
would be the only thing warming it up
whereas on a hot day like the popsicle
like you get a higher amount of popsicle
delivered per lick because it's melting
under the power of our giant space laser
it's the whole dynamic of like the hot
day melting the popsicle and like
licking the stuff coming off the melted
popsicle and I feel like I feel like
you're ruining that by taking this like
like it like a balanced dynamic and then
being like like introducing like manual
slicing and crushing to it which is not
supposed to be like I think if you talk
to mr. pop and mrs. sickle they would
tell you that that's not what they
invented the popsicle for you know not
to spin off into a weird tangent but I'm
going to do just that it's one of my I
really like the concept of like
conditional enjoyment of food based on
like the weather cuz that's a thing
right like I love hot chopped but like
it's 95 degrees in August I'm not going
to drink hot shopkins and roast that
sounds terrible mm-hm
you know and like I love tea I love like
a nice hot tea once again it's not what
I'm reaching for it like five o'clock on
the afternoon on a July afternoon and
vice versa if it's like you know Febuary
and it's 20 degrees out I'm not like you
know what I could go for pops it yeah
well there's also like so for I have to
I have to additions to this one I have a
baby and I will often wear him on my
front so that like like so that it's
easy to walk around and he's just like
in my front pack and it's super cute
wintertime my baby had just been born at
the coffee shop and I'm ordering an iced
coffee it like negative 20 and they're
like what are you thinking and I'm like
they say you can't have a hot coffee
around your baby like I'm gonna spill it
right on his poor newborn head that has
never had anything bad happened to it
and so I have to drink iced cot and it
was weird
to order an iced coffee when it was like
negative below zero out so one that's
one thing second we live in this world
where like all produce is available all
the time now and I think that's great
but it's also kind of sad that like
there isn't anything that just happens
sometime
and you're like waiting excitedly for
cherry season to arrive because in
Montana we have cherry season as we have
cherry trees here and suddenly for like
a very short period of time they're
extremely expensive and plentiful
delicious cherries
in inexpensive did I say expensive they
are inexpensive because they're trying
to get rid of them during this window
before all the chairs go bad and I love
it so much when cherry season arrives
and you can go and like to the fruit
stand and be like yes here's five
dollars for 13 pounds of cherries I I
will also say as long as we're talking
about foods and different temperatures
and Families he's also one of my
favorite things about like when I got
married or you guys I'd say wouldn't my
then girlfriend now wife and I started
living together it's you encounter all
these different foods that like you and
their family and your family just do
differently and like one of them is my
wife whenever she buys like Cool Whip it
lives in the freezer for her Oh haired
yeah and like listen I'm not against it
it's not like it ruins it or anything
but like the first couple of times I
found it I kind of just like shift my
head like well she actually really put
it in the freezer I'm like moved into
the fridge and then she was apparently
doing the reverse of that and there's
like things like that throughout where
it's like no this goes in the fridge
like I keep apples in the refrigerator
and she doesn't the apples live in the
fridge and she's like why yeah I'm like
be because that is where they go but I
can't imagine as a person with sensitive
teeth eating like biting into an apple
that's been in the fridge well see but I
think in my mind is a matter of like the
cold will slow down the spoiling process
right no I understand but I would never
do that
Travis yessing I feel like I have to I
have to quote you and and turn to our
question asker here and say I apologize
to your family for yucking in there YUM
don't you can their YUM they can eat
popsicles however they want I will say
this though you don't have to watch them
eat popsicles and I recommend that you
do not
um much like I don't like watching
people chew on hard things cuz it makes
my teeth Lincoln it's my teeth on edge
to use to turn a phrase and so like you
should not watch people buy into cold
things cuz it will they might destroy
your San Bay and that is where we were
going to end this episode of dear Hank
and John with Travis McElroy Travis you
are at a bunch of podcasts and yeah if
you don't know I'm macro shaws.com if
you want to there it is
and I appreciate you hanging out with me
for this extra special and short edition
of dear Hank and John well thank you so
much for having me this episode of dear
Hank and John was edited by me and it
was produced by me and everything was
done by me because I didn't want to mess
with anybody and give them extra work to
do Thank You me for do it open it
Travis you're great hey you're good and
as they say in our hometown again the
pod con IndieGoGo will only be up for
just a couple more days after that there
will be tickets for sale at pod con-com
but they will be more expensive and some
of the stuff we have on the IndieGoGo
will only be available during the
campaign pod con is an event for people
who make podcasts and for people who
love them and we will be joined by a
bunch of amazing podcasters including
the McElroy brothers of them that
brother my brother and me the creators
of welcome to night Vale Roman Mars of
99% invisible Aaron manky of lore
Franchesca Ramsey and Patrick Kondos of
last name basis Phebe judge and Lauren
spoor of criminal Gaby Dunn of bad with
money Cecil Baldwin Dylan Marin Jessica
Cole we're adding new people all the
time as we continue to plan the event
I'm super excited for really looking
forward to it and I hope that I will see
you there